this podcast clip is taken from an
interview I did with David Ike that has
since been deleted by YouTube I don't
know why it was deleted it was up to
early a million views make of that what
you will I know the conspiracy theorists
out there are going to jump all over
this but a lot of you have been
complaining that you were watching it
and you really wanted to see the rest of
it so I'm going to do my best to make a
couple of Clips out of this so that you
can still watch it that being said we
have another interesting podcast coming
out on Monday with a researcher who goes
even deeper into one of David ik's
theories which is the ancient alien
Civilization now this researcher has
read tablets that are thousands of years
old and claims that he has evidence that
aliens were here they made us they made
the pyramids and a whole lot of other
stuff and you are going to have your
minds blown you think you know what the
Garden of Eden was in the Bible turns
out it wasn't two people who had a few
kids and a few more and then populated
the Earth so this podcast is one of the
most interesting I think I've ever done
I can't wait to see what you all think
about it in the comments check it out
this Monday evening I'll see you there
but for now enjoy the
clip when I started looking around these
different ancient cultures and and
religions you know one of the things
that strikes me as I as I've researched
this over the years is not how things
are so different but it's the things
that people agree on it's the things
that are the same I'm always looking for
patterns of of of agreement over the you
know the eons of what we call time and
you find
whether you're looking at religions or
whether you're looking at um ancient
cultures MH you'll find there is this
agreement this reality this world we
call human is
manipulated from The
Unseen these are the pantheons of Gods
like the Greek gods and all these other
gods that that people worship but can't
see according to mainstream science the
electromagnetic spectrum which is
basically our reality
is
0.05% of what exists in energy in all
its forms in the universe
0.05% some say it's as high as 0.5%
doesn't matter
tiny visible light which is the only
band of frequency we could see is a
smear a fraction of the
0.05% so we are basically blind right
it's very hard for people to accept that
though it's it's easy to say to them
Wi-Fi is in this room right now but you
can't see it but people can't really
wrap their head around what you're
saying but if if they if they want to
understand the world they need to wrap
their head around it because so many
things they are waving away as
impossible this uh explains why they're
not when something um is operating
outside of visible light say it's a uar
and an entity when it enters visible
light to The Observer it's come out of
nowhere it hasn't but it's come into
your uh visual reality out of nowhere
and when it leaves it's gone out of your
visual reality I I started looking at
this and and doing all the uh ancient
cultures and the religions and you find
this theme of a non-human force with
negative intent on Humanity that is
manipulating our world from The Unseen
so if you look at
Christianity they have the devil and
Satan that's their name for this uh
Force collectively and they talk about
demons then you look at Islam now Islam
of course is completely different from
Christianity of course it is so people
think but actually there are big areas
of agreement and one of them is the
Jin and the Jin are a uh considered to
be a force in the hidden that manipulate
human society and their Collective name
for the the ruler of the
Jin Christian Satan
Islam
Shayan or I then you look at um the
Gnostic uh belief system and there were
um uh documents found like um ancient
documents found at a place called nagami
in Egypt which was about 75 80 mies
north of
luxa um on the side of the Nile and in
1945 they found an earth and
jar that
estimate uh these documents were placed
in around 400 ad but the um content of
the documents goes further back and a
fifth of these documents they're known
as the nagadi library now are describing
a non-human Force manipulating Humanity
from the hidden which they call
archons which in Greek means
rulers see why they called them that and
their devil figure and Shayan Elis
figure is called the demiurge or yaler
beo then I I talk to the great Zulu
Shaman crater muta in South Africa spent
days and days talking to him who
describes their Legends and accounts of
a non-human Force manipulating human
society which they say took a reptilian
um reptilian form and all around the
world you pick up this same
theme um and then um as I was
investigating uh because if you if you
if you go back in what we call ancient
history the Ancients were doing
sacrificial rituals to these Gods right
and
um they were sacrificing particularly
children the reason for that there was
actually one found recently the Frozen
girl she was a sacrific that like 13,000
years old or whatever I can't remember
how long yeah but what they what they
did um was they in those days because it
was acceptable God knows why they did it
openly right and and and it was um a
sacrifice to the gods and I'll come to
this in a second but my question was so
what do the freaking Gods get out of it
then well I now understand and then I'm
investigating these rich and famous
billionaires of today who are players in
this cult and again and again and again
I'm led into Satanism and pedophilia
those two are absolutely
connected um for reasons I explain in
the
books and what are these bloody
billionaires doing Satanic ritual
sacrifices to to their version of the
Gods right like the old God where we SE
in the footage that Alex Jones took yeah
in Bohemian grow stuff George Bush and
all of them were there Al Gore was there
they're they're doing it to the same
Gods right the same freaking entities
that the Ancients were doing the
sacrifices to and were terrified
of these people today are doing the
sacrifices to in the
coal um and I've talked to people all
over the world um over the decades I've
been doing this a long time um 34 years
I'm I've been doing it now they coming
up 34 years and I've met satanists and
people that took part in rituals against
their will who have have told me of
their experiences and the these are
major major players like the royal
family British royal family Dutch royal
family all that stuff all major players
in this um in this satanic uh ritual um
culture um and so then I asked that
question I I mentioned a few minutes ago
oh so what did the gods get out of it I
take you back to the first Matrix movie
and the Morpheus character holds up a
battery and he says the Matrix is a
computer generated dream world designed
to turn humans into one of these a
battery and that's when uh a massive
understanding started to uh started to
come to me from many different sources
which I talk about in the
books
these quote Gods these entities are
feeding off
human energy but it's a particular type
of human
energy um this is mainstream science
again every time we feel emotion every
time we think we're generating
frequencies and those frequencies in
terms of what the frequencies are relate
to the nature of the emotion and the
nature of the thought and scientists
have worked out what these frequencies
are are for different emotions right and
um it's all like when you go into a room
and you kind of feel like oh there's a a
bad energy in here yeah know I mean yeah
I mean if if you go into like an old
house where there's been a lot of um
really bad things going on there see
when the bad things are going on the
people involved in the bad things are
giving off that Vibe and unless someone
goes into that house and changes the
frequency they sit there vibrating so
you go into it and you think oh this is
horrible God because you're picking the
vibe up right so this is these are the
energies I'm talking about so these
entities by their very
nature um are very low vibrational in
nature because anyone that wants to
impose their will and manipulate and
cause suffering and War and death and
destruction is in a very low vibrational
State and if they're going to feed off
human energy they can only feed of it if
we are delivering it within the band of
frequency they can absorb because um
otherwise if we were uh in a world of
love and joy and happiness and peace
then we'd be giving off frequencies yes
but much higher more expanded
frequencies and they wouldn't be able to
absorb them like radio stations in the
old analog system sharing the same space
but not interfering with each other
because they're on different wavelengths
so we're living in a in a world and
again it's about perceptual
control that is absolutely nothing like
the one we appear to be experiencing you
have this demonic
hierarchy and then you have the human
hierarchy which is prime ministers and
presidents and the king in this one in
this country um and that hierarchy is
for public consumption this hierarchy is
the one that's calling the shots the
royal families um are
royal and consider themselves special
Bloodlines the Blue
Bloods because they uh are vehicles for
this demonic realm to enter our realm is
that why they only like even now they're
very picky with who they let in the
family right yeah apart from Jimmy savil
of course but he was serving them as
they as they want because there's a
reason why they uh why the vast vast
numbers of them are pedophiles and now
what we have um is a rump royal family
you've got Charles um uh and then you've
got William and his kids then are very
very young you've got
um Prince Harry and his Handler megal
marle um who are firing missiles across
the bloody Atlantic at the raw family
and why have you I've got a question
about him actually because you in quite
good detail broke
down the fate of Diana and that the
likelihood is she was killed do you
think that the prince hurry and Megan's
situation has been brought about by him
suspecting that his mother was murdered
but I I I don't know all all I can say
is that when you look at the evidence if
you don't realize it was a murder in
fact ritual murder in many ways then uh
you're not paying attention I mean it's
so uh bloody obvious I mean you know the
the the symbolism they they they love
their symbolism uh these this cult it's
all about symbolism in so many ways it's
their language I remember once uh you
kind of did a tour of London where you
were pointing out how much satanic and
Royal symbolism are the same yeah they
are they are and uh if you um if you
look at the the Diana thing I mean Diana
was the ancient Moon Goddess right and
um do you mean like that was the name
actually of yeah the Ancients used to
worship Diana as a goddess goddess of
the moon Etc and uh Pont Dalma tunnel
where she died is called the British
translates as the bridge or passage of
the Moon Goddess I mean these these
people um they absolutely love the
symbolism and if you can start to
understand the language of symbolism you
can see they're putting they're telling
us but of course they know most people
don't know this language of symbolism
but they're telling us so yeah she she
she was um she was murdered for sure um
and even with the Royal wear and the the
cloak and everything like and some of
these um these big fraking gold sticks
where they've got um emblems on them
you've pointed all of that out and
brought it back to what it really means
yeah well you you look I mean it's
relatively topical you look at the uh
corination of Prince Charles I mean it
was all symbolism it was all um satanic
esoteric symbolism I met a a guy once um
whose mother was a psychic lady and she
was into all the esoteric and he said
you know my mother uh can predict the
colors that the queen mother is going to
wear any
day because it's all according to the
esoteric calendar what does esoteric
mean hidden okay um uh what What's
called the occult uh
um a cult is just a word meaning hidden
it's it's that which is hidden things
such as like the Checker flaws and stu
stuff like that it's it's it's all
symbolism and it's all in some way
interacting with with energy to
manipulate energy in a certain way the
Satanic rituals are all the way they're
conducted is to manipulate the energetic
field um and what they do is um do the
same rituals in the same places
over and over and over again and what
that does is it thins
because um what these rituals are doing
like I said earlier is they're
interacting with these uh lower astral
quote Gods demons entities and the more
they do it in the same place they thin
out the dimensional difference at that
point between our world and that world
and I've been described been described
to me many times by satanists how um
these entities in the major rituals slip
through from their Dimension into this
one and appear appear in front of the
satanists um so um could that be almost
like a vision like you know how people
have um Visions while meditating a lot
of people could that be on or or do you
mean literally they appear physic
literally they appear but they can't
stay for long because there there is a
vibrational difference between how what
they're vibrating on and and and and
what this vibrating on but they can come
in for a short time and then and then
they they leave you mentioned earlier
about Wi-Fi and stuff well if um I said
to people that knew nothing about
computers um that there was a field of
information in this room that you could
tap into anywhere in the world if you
had the right kit there people would say
you're mad mate what you're talking
about I can't see it where is it cuz cuz
the 5 cents um Centric people which is
most people because they are encouraged
and manipulated to be five cense
Centric their Arbiter of everything is
can I see it touch it taste it hear it
um uh see it Etc um but that is such a
tiny band of frequency it's it's
laughable the world we think we're in is
so tiny do you know 99.9 this is
mainstream science
99.9% of the universe is
plasma it's not physical at all it's
plasma and what they call the atomic
level which is made up of atoms but
atoms themselves are empty gives you a
clue this is not solid is a tiny
smear of the universe and that tiny
smear is what our narrow band of visible
uh light is connected to to se so we're
looking at this smear and and the rest
of the universe exists all around us
including with these entities in it but
we're not aware of it because we're not
aware of it we think it doesn't exist it
actually uh uh does so you've got this
wi-fi and if you say to people now who
know about computers and know about
Wi-Fi uh you say the same you know
there's a field of information in this
room that you can tap into anywhere the
world people say oh yeah yeah Wi-Fi I
know about that yeah and the only
difference between I know about that and
you're mad is knowledge that's all it is
so the more you can manipulate knowledge
and suppress knowledge the more people
will dismiss what's actually happening
because they can't perceive that it's
possible to happen because that
knowledge has been kept from them and so
uh what you have with this cult is Two
Worlds in one world you have the secret
society Network I've described which is
fiercely compartmentalized only the
inner core really know the story and
then you've got the
population and what's happening is the
knowledge of reality and the knowledge
of where humanity is being
taken is kept in the cult and it's
passed over through the
generations and the same cult has
created the education system in America
it was created by the Rockefellers not
least JD
Rockefeller um and uh they they own the
media they own the sources of
information apart from you know people
who are working uh to uh to uncover this
stuff and so that uh information source
to the population is designed to be as
narrow as possible so that people have
no bloody idea what they know and when
people like me start uncovering through
sweat and and spit um what they know and
passing it on to the population a lot of
the population go you're mad mate and
that's the idea it reminds me of an
interview you had with um scoffield
Philip scoffield and he said oh so you
want to go against the system it would
just be chaos and you replied bombing
kids from the sky Isa is chaos and
that's what I against you know what I
mean like I am fascinated by this idea
that there's a gap in human history
where things changed and I know you've
talked a little bit about some of the
anunaki side of uh you know we were once
visited by aliens who then sort of
changed us genetically and then we would
then look more like them and do do you
think that there's a cross um a bit
where the demons and aliens are the same
thing or are they completely different I
think overwhelmingly they are the same
thing yeah um and um I think the uh oh
this is going to be controversial Brian
well we like that so many of the
religions are worshiping the wrong quote
chap the
bloodthirsty
arrogant um
Tyrant of a god described in the Old
Testament is the demons um and I I think
a lot of these uh Gods that people uh
worship or their version of God in the
different religions are actually these
this this demonic realm and what makes
you think that you know you read the Old
Testament God and I mean he's is he's a
tyrant he's a bloodthirsty bloody Tyrant
oh he's a loving God why why don't seem
like it I've read some of the passages
they don't look like it uh and and oh
you must only uh worship me you know and
in these Gnostic documents found in 1945
supposed to have been put in that jar in
around 400 ad
um they quote Yol Deo uh the Demi urge
their version of the devil Satan shaan
El and they quote him almost word for
word saying the bloody same you must not
um worship any God but me I am the only
God and all that stuff they talk about
you know is it the sons of God who
interbred with the daughters of men and
created the the the this uh uh Nephilim
race or whatever can can you explain
that just a little bit cuz that that is
a lot of people don't know about that
theory well that that's a a line in the
Bible about the the the sons of God Sons
of the Gods sons of the Gods it actually
says it's been translated as sons of God
singular actually means what it says
translated from says sons of the Gods
plural um and it talks about the the
interbreeding between uh the sons of
God and humans creating this this this
Nephilim type race they talked about and
from you look at other sources of other
cultures and they'll tell you the same
story yeah basic story I mean the Adam
and Eve story you can find that in many
different cultures told in different
ways the biblical stories are actually
an amalgamation of stories that go much
further back and and have been put in
another location and put in another
context it is funny that the similar
characters that show themselves in all
of these different books written by
different people thousands of years
apart yeah exactly um so you um you have
this biological computer that's actually
decoding The Matrix
which is why when the computer
biological computer ceases to function
in other words what we call death MH
Consciousness uh leaves the body cuz the
biological computer is no longer
decoding The Matrix because it's not
functioning anymore so Consciousness
leaves and and this is when you you see
all the a stunning numbers of stories
now around the world of near-death
experiences where they talk about they
experienced a completely different
reality which clearly had a very
different law of physics right now this
is interesting I said earlier
when uh just after the turn of the
Millennium I had this overwhelming
feeling that this is a
simulation and that the limit of the
simulation at this level there are
others is a speed of light and speed of
light only appears to scientists like
Einstein to be the fast his speed CU
it's it's limited to this
reality and at the time that I got this
feeling uh very strongly and started
talking about it um I I obviously looked
around and and and thought well is
anyone else getting this stuff about
we're living a simulation and I found
one guy that's all a guy called Nick
Bostrom at professor at um Oxford
University who was saying that he felt
this could be a simulation but he the
way he saw it was different to me and
then as the years of passed I started
writing about it and as the years have
passed uh more and more mainstream
scientists one only two weeks ago that
was in all the papers in in Britain in
Portsmouth University I've I've started
to say both sides of the Atlantic and in
Japan and places like that it does look
like this is a
simulation and
um if you go down the road of the
simulation
hypothesis all these mysteries of life
that cannot be explained by the official
version of this reality start to get
answered then in uh April 2021 there was
an article in Scientific American
mainstream Science magazine in obviously
in America and it was an academic and
said he' um
concluded that this is a simulation and
that the limit of it is the speed of
light and it fell off me bloody chair
the laws of physics what we call the
laws of physics are the limits of the
game as encoded into the game
creators of the G which is why when when
when people leave conscious leaves the
body leaves the decoding mechanism of
the Matrix uh the the biological
computer they experience a world with a
very different law of physics the law of
physics that we have is only limited to
this this uh uh reality a scientist I
know he actually became a believer in a
Creator and a God when he was looking at
blood under a microscope because he said
he could see the design of the love of
blood he said I could almost see the the
Fingerprints of whoever created us right
there the patterns were there it's like
this isn't an accident it's not an
accident it's a creation but the I mean
you know told by mainstream scientists a
lot that we are just um little specks
you know of dust almost that here by
fluke Chance by a complete Big Bang
accident that just so happened and now
we're all here living our lives out and
when you look off into the universe we
can see how minute we are and how
unimportant we
are but yet we've never explored any of
it and you know even what we have
explored turned out that didn't even
look like that was real right the moon
landing for example well that's a that's
that's a great point and and and which
I've written about in the books
um Are we more important than we are led
to believe well yes we are because we're
Consciousness and we're part of the
infinite uh uh Realm Of Consciousness
therefore we're as powerful as that
infinite range of Consciousness
ultimately but what what the the the the
Matrix does the simulation is it holds
us in a perceptual prison cell that
convinces us that's why this is
happening convinces us that we're
insignificant and and just little me and
we've got no power if if you if you want
to control billions of people isn't that
billions of expressions of Consciousness
in human bodies isn't that what you want
them to believe and then there's this
other point um there was a guy called
fery um who um after whom something
called the fery Paradox is uh named and
he looked up into the nights Sky not
surprisingly and he said where's the
freaking
aliens there all those lights there's
all those planets they talk about
billions of of of stars and billions of
planets and billions of universes
whatever where's the bloody aliens now
if you were creating a
simulation and your target you wanted to
keep in total ignorance of everything so
they they would just be your um your
cattle to farm of energy you don't want
interaction with uh the outside the
outside that's going to widen your
perspective of of of of what's going on
you want to look into the night sky and
feel alone and feel insignificant feel
small it's all um that that is there for
and what are they manipulating we keep
coming back to it they manipul in our
perception um
so do you think they're lying about
what's outside of our atmosphere as in
when I say they I mean like let's say
NASA for example who are heavily funded
by the American taxpayer beyond belief
with very little to actually show for it
other than we went to the moon God knows
50 odd years ago and somehow destroyed
the technology that can take we back
there but we'll get go there again
something do cuz NASA specifically a
company that I just do not trust the
word they say cuz there's so little to
show for how much well you know NASA
came about um came about as a result of
of of Nazi
scientists um uh it was an eagle race
basically towards the end of the war the
uh second world war um there was
something called Project Paperclip this
has been well documented now um where
the Americans um the American expression
of the cult the cult has no borders
there for there for public consumption
um organized um something like 1600
probably a lot more but we know of 1600
scientists Nazi scientists out of um
Germany to um America and they were
created they created NASA which really
should be called Nazi really um and uh
one they were literally Nazi SST yeah
one of them one of them was Verna Von
braa who uh designed the V2 rockets that
that attacked London in the second world
war and then he went to America and um
helped to set up NASA and he designed
the Saturn five rockets of the Apollo uh
missions right so he um he he was a
great example of it and he was a Nazi
and and and because there's no borders
this is why the Rockefellers were
funding the Nazis there's no borders the
US versus them is only in the mind of
the people right yeah so the people
fight each other that's all it is so
NASA is never going to tell you about
one or two people working there might
who are not in the uh the Inner Circle
um and and often at the end of their
careers before they retire but they're
not going to uh uncover the great
secrets of the universe why because they
don't bloody want you to know them
that's the point I'm talking about the
inner core that controls NASA um so
fully enough in I think it was 2017
there was a NASA computer scientist I
think he's retired pretty soon
afterwards called Rich terill um who um
came out in the in the media and said um
he' concluded that this is a
simulation it's a holographic simulation
exactly what I was saying just after the
turn of the Millennium and that as a
result it can't be natural and if it's
not natural then some intelligence must
have created it yes that demonic Force
we're talking about so um you um you you
have the um the body
decoding the simulation into a reality
that appears one way but it's actually
nothing like it now here's a
analogy what I'm seeing
um so obviously as the years go on is
that this explosion of technology that
is um taking over human society and
running it through
AI is
mimicking uh the way that we decode
reality and what reality is the reality
we're experiencing how are the are the
virtual reality Games impacting up on
our
reality well you put a headset on 5
cents eyes you put the uh head
headphones on 5 cents hearing you put
the gloves on 5 cents touch and so on
and so forth they're overriding and
hacking in to our five sense decoding
system and which is communicated to the
brain which then decodes it into a sense
of reality in the same way that we are
have you ever been in one of those by
the way they're they're unbelievable
like you really really are like it takes
a few seconds to get used to it but once
you're in there you really do forget
that there is another world yeah you're
in there now you know that's a very
that's a very interesting comment
because of what I'm going to say and the
more sophisticated and advanced they
become the closer and closer and closer
they're getting to a sense of reality in
the game that is like the one we're
having when we take the headset off
doesn't that go back to what you were
saying about humans belief that the the
technology we have right now has to be
the most advanced and the idea that
something more advanced could have been
created thousands of years ago we can't
comprehend that but it is very possible
yeah well I want to talk about I'll
mention when I finish this next bit
about the biological is that really
natural who says um so what what what
you have with the virtual reality game
is if you go on the internet there's
loads of them and you look at a
compilation
of the reactions of people not even with
the gloves on and the hearing but just
the headset yep and they're screaming
they're falling over they're jumping all
they are ABS their reality has been
completely taken
over by um what's coming out and through
the
headset but then they can
go oh it's just a game right now
what if this biological computer was the
equivalent of a five sense not just one
sense a five sense
headset and the only way you could take
it off your
Consciousness is if you leave this
reality if you die yeah so you're in the
womb and your your body computer is
developing you come out of the womb and
there's your parents they've got
headsets on your siblings got headsets
on you go to school the teachers have
got headsets on all your mates have got
headsets on you turn on the television
someone's reading the news with a
freaking headset on you go out into the
world of work and everyone has got
headsets on believing this reality to be
real and you are going to have the
headset on decoding The Matrix
constantly until you leave this world
and you go through an experience where
you leave the body and you're in a
different realm of physics because this
is no longer functioning you are going
to believe Brian clearly just look at
the compilations on the internet of a
game you're going to believe that this
reality is as it seems to be and what
you're being told is what is the real
world when actually it's just a decoding
mechanism people say um biological is
natural okay it's a natural body and
natural trees and all that stuff I'm not
saying these things don't exist in some
other reality of which this is a copy I
mean the uh a a bad copy as the gnostics
described it in their documents this is
a bad copy of uh of of prime reality
kind of like where we had the Garden of
Eden and then another version which
we're now living in and you trick them
into it now this is interesting Garden
of Eden um Who tricked Who tricked them
the snake snake what's that symbolic of
I've said to Christian people do you
really think that that's describing a
talking snake it's all symbolic it's all
SYM
and then you say well what happened is
that brought them into the to the to the
to the Trap is they saw good and evil
what's that polarity polarity this whole
simulation is polarity it's basically an
electrical system it's an electrical
electromagnetic system that's that this
level that we're we we're experiencing
the rest is plasma it's this electrical
level and and electricity requires
polarity which is why you know and and
and and what's happening is they're
trying to get the population to respond
to that polarity all the time I remember
hearing you once describe the the
situation we're in with the world right
now is imbalance imbalance yeah well
what we need in my view is one hand
freaking clapping and then we might get
somewhere because what happens is
imposition imposition polarity
resistance to the imposition polarity oh
you've got electrical system now we
don't need resistance we need to say
we're not doing it we're not cooperating
and then you've got one hand clapping
and and you've taken the polarity out
you've taken the Falls AP the the the
system that connects you both you know I
mean Israel and and Hamas are two
polarities in an electrical system and
the people taking the consequences are
the the the civilians on both sides
caught up in it it's everywhere you look
it's it's U it's its polarity um and so
what I said to people say to people is
the natural world is natural the
biological is natural oh yeah okay so
what you comparing it with well I'm
comparing it with the um with te techn
technology and techn yeah but how do you
know that the biological is not a far
far more advanced version of Technology
how do you know that unless you have
something that you solid gold
irrefutably know is natural you can't
you have nothing to compare it with you
only compare it with a technological
which makes it look natural this cult in
a core knows it's not natural and it
treats it as a form of Technology that's
what it that's how it treats the
biological you know when you're having a
dream and you don't know it's a dream
you are being emotionally and mentally
impacted by The Dream you know you I
mean nightmare is a is a is a classic
example of what I'm talking about but
have you had these dreams I have a lot
of
these where you're in you're having a
dream but you know it's a freaking dream
yeah have you ever that oh yeah well
what happens you're not emotionally and
mentally impacted upon it anymore you're
the Observer you're observing the dream
because you know it's a
dream you do things in a completely
different way like the you know like the
fight or flight type dreams uh which
I've had a lot of for whatever reason I
think it's a normal thing for Block but
you you you seem sort of passive don't
you like you feel like yeah whatever
happens happens I know this isn't
yeah it's a completely different
attitude completely different that's
kind of like Enlightenment I suppose
exactly you starting to sus it um so
when you um when you're living in this
reality you're in this world of course
you are cuz while you're in a body it's
going to be decoding The Matrix into the
reality you think you're experiencing
but consciously you know it's a dream
you know it's an induced dream you know
it's an illusion and what happens is it
the more the more more it becomes part
of you not just a concept but part of
you the more your life becomes not
totally because you know this the the
impact emotionally on people is constant
but to a vastly greater extent you um
become the Observer of the dream and
things that used to impact upon you the
drama oh my God have you heard the
latest oh see was Happ to so and so
oh you're detached you're you're
observing it you know it's oh
[Music]
nonsense